l' affaire commence alors que tu à 19
ans tu rêve de faire du mannequinat tu
trouves un photographe pour prendre des
photos c'est ça en fait oui j'ai
commencé assez jeune j'avais 13 ans
quand j'ai commencé tout ça et puis
c'est passé un palier un petit peu plus
au dessus voilà quand j'avais 19 ans il
ya un petit peu tout le monde qui te dis
voilà ben tu devrais faire des photos et
puis on se lance et c'était l'époque des
books en ligne je pense que ça existe
toujours et
on rencontre ont fait plusieurs
rencontres de photographes et puis à un
moment donné avec un photographe ça
dérape ça se passe très mal c'est à dire
il paraît qu'il a un comportement et des
goûts très sympa promo alors en fait
vous disiez tout à l'heure qu'on vous
avait annoncé sujet vous disiez photos
volées en fait elles n'ont pas été volés
on a extorqué les photos d'accord voilà
à l'époque quand c'est sorti quand le
scandale a éclaté j'ai été incapable de
m'en expliquer le ciel m'est tombé sur
la tête ça a été très dur - d'accord
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec ce
photographe ben je pensais arriver dans
un studio photo il se trouve que je me
retrouve enfermé chez un mec que je ne
connais pas il a fermé sa porte à clé
pendant un mois la pression alors donc
je vous dis j'ai lu ça dans voyez vous
dit je vais te demander des quartiers
des jambes oui au bout d'un moment ça
n'a pas été tout de suite au début ce
n'était pas du tout ce genre de photos
qu'on devait faire parce que savoir que
c'est un photographe qui signait oui
enfin je ne sais pas à l'heure actuelle
mais signé des éditos de son nom je veux
dire il travaillait une grande agence de
mannequins qu'en dit qu'on voit la bac
complètement j'en fais complètement
confiance et au bout d'un moment donc je
devais faire des photos de portraits
visage parce que moi c'était du visage
qui passait bien j'avais voilà j'avais
pas le corps qu'il fallait et petit à
petit on vous amène
s'éteint au roulement psychologique
c'est du harcèlement sexuel mais j'étais
incapable de monde expliquait à l'époque
donc maintenant j'ai pris de la
bouteille j'ai 30 ans j'ai fait ma vie
je suis capable de mettre des mots sur
tout cela et je pense que le bouquin que
j'ai fait que j'ai écrit neuf mois pour
accoucher de ça c'est pas anodin comme
chiffres je suis maman de deux enfants
il fait 4 135 pages et jeudi tout alors
je pense qu'il faut alerter à l'élite je
te l'aï dit je vais te demandé d'écarter
les jambes de fixer l'objectif en
prenant un air de passer ça
donc quand vous sentez à ce moment là
quand vous sortez de votre
je voudrais dire aussi que quand j'ai vu
effectivement les photos dans le
magazine ce que les gens ne savent pas
c'est que je ne me rappelle pas m'être
retrouvé complètement donc ça a été
terriblement choquant pour moi c'est à
dire je ne me rappelle pas de du
basculement quand je me suis retrouvée
nue je ne m'en souviens pas je ne sais
pas ce qui s'est passé
je ne sais pas donc je ça j'arrive à
d'expliquer très bien dans ces la
première scène du livre elle est très
détaillé jeudi tout ce dont je me
rappelle
et voilà moi c'était important pour moi
de faire votre plateau ce que la
jeunesse de france vous regarde je veux
alerter les jeunes filles de ce système
dans le système que c'est très rare ce
qui se passe que parfois même pour faire
des castings pour enfin il ya maintenant
on veut des jeunes rêvent de faire
secret story on leur dit voilà tout ce
monde se fait passer pour le directeur
de casting il te suffit d'envoyer un new
de voir un petit peu ce que tu veux
donner une vidéo un peu dénudée je suis
je suis le directeur et au final j'en
parlais avec une directrice de casting
juste avant de venir sur votre plateau
où elle me disais mais j'ai des plantes
de jeunes de parents qui me disent on a
demandé à mon enfant il faut dénoncer ça
aujourd'hui ça va alors quelques années
plus tard le comité miss france vous
contactez votre profil est intéressant
et tu en contact avec un coach du comité
miss france et tu décides de lui parler
des photos voilà et que tu as prise il
ya quelques années alors qu'ici ce
monsieur n'était pas connue
officiellement du comité miss france il
a eu cette chasse après mais bon c'était
un petit peu officieux d'accord et là il
prenait soin de ne jamais en parler m'a
dit écoute si ça sorte unis en bloc mais
ça ne sortira pas et c'est vrai que
juste avant il ya vu le précédent
valérie bègue j'étais pétrifiée que ça
m'arrive mais moi j'avais prévu le
photographe j'ai dit voilà je vais
peut-être tenter ma chance s'il te plaît
garde ça pour toi ce qu'en plus j'ai eu
une éducation très
très prude très catholique donc voila
c'était la catastrophe moi il m'a dit
écoute moi je suis un photographe qui
tient à sa réputation ça ne sortira pas
et puis j'étais rassuré parce que chez
lui avait plein de boue enfin en studio
chez lui plein de boue qui avaient de
grandes agences avaient faim c'est très
rassurant tout ça alors en 2009 tu te
dire miss paris doit donc participer à
miss france je termine dans les douze
dernières du concours c'est malika
ménard qui remplace celle héritée du
même pas été dans la hâte et malika
ménard qui qui
vous avez même plutôt concours à cause
de ses photos mais si moi j'ai fait le
concours mais j'ai même pas été dans les
deux hommes voilà ça c'est quand même le
concours oui c'est ça j'ai fait le
concours et c'est ce qui s'est passé à
miss france encore quelques jours après
jours après ouais les photos sans
quelques jours après on prévient c'est
le côté d'ailleurs qui me prévient qui
me dit écoute
c'est catastrophique je crois que je te
reconnais entrevue fait le teasing de la
couverture à du numéro à venir et
je crois que je te reconnais donc
derrière les photos sortent paraît que
c'est un traumatisme pour vous oui les
gens s'imaginent pas la violence
votre famille en plus ouais ouais mais
wayne ces gens s'imaginent pas la
violence que ça peut être mais je suis
là aussi pour montrer que ben on peut
s'en remettre qu'il suffit de faire tout
ça c'est de la force mentale en fait je
vois là il ya 12 ans qui sont écoulés
c'est vrai que je détaille beaucoup ce
passage il ya eu une grosse dépression
il ya eu j'ai même en faisant le livre
où il ya de nombreuses révélations j'ai
même retrouvé une lettre donc je voulais
me suicider que je n'en voyais à tout le
monde j'ai retrouvé ça à mon âge
maintenant g35 balej la petite kenya
l'après alors il y en a une que tu
n'épargne pas ses jeunes gars devront
d'études y avoir subi un acharnement de
la part du comité miss france
de la part de geneviève de fontenay pas
de la part du comité mais vraiment de la
part de jeunes j'ai franchement c'est
pas vie n'épargne pas je retranscris
noir sur blanc les propos qu'elle a eue
je pense que vu le livre que je tiens
enfin qui sort la une doit sortir les
propos les propos qui allaient me
c'était quoi ah bah voilà par exemple
que te dire que j'étais que je suis
ignoble abominable qu'elle aille au
diable à l'amour andré comte vendée
bruno comme ça
c'est quand même elle qui a écarté les
cuisses on va pas s'apitoyer sur son
sort
oui je les huées en fait elle ne mollit
pas sur ses propos coin je lui dit que
vous étiez là et elle m'a dit mais c'est
une absence de dignité chez vous vous
n'avez pas deux neurones sur la scène du
photographe à elle dit mais qu'elle se
débrouille avec ça en fait elle reste
sur une position extrêmement dur je
passe des mots très violents car a tenu
à votre rencontre mais comment vous
expliquer qu'aujourd'hui encore elle ne
veut pas entendre parler d'où elle ne
regrette rien et s'il fallait ou
destituer encore elle vous destituerait
je pense que bon je pense que c'est une
femme âgée qui vit vraiment dans une
autre temps par temporalité moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour les gens
vraiment voilà je pense y voilà je les
insulte pas dans mon livre je pense
qu'elle vit vraiment dans une autre
étoile et moralité et qu'elle n'a pas
confiance mais j'adore quand woods autre
temporalité moi je suis de ma
temporalité de moulins de paix enfin
tout va bien le souci moi ce qui me
dérange c'est que vous dites que vous
avez eu une amnésie donc du coup il ya
même plus d'histoire au delà de
l'amnésie moi j'ai vu ces photos pour
les besoins de l'émission avant je
connaissais pas ces photos c'est même
pas des photos sexy parce que moi des
photos sexy j'en ai fait en
sous-vêtements j'en ai fait là c'est des
photos pornographiques je vais même dire
que même des photos pornographiques sont
plus propres que ce que vous avez mangé
voûtée des photos oui je n'ai de fond
des ford et le cracher dessus elle dit
vous écarter les cuisses soin ses skis
et puisque vous avez les cuisses
écartées je dirais même plus on voit
plus vos doigts parce que vaudois sont à
l'intérieur de vous jouer des choses que
vous êtes en train de dire vous rendez
compte que jamais la laisser les jeunes
filles qui nous écoutent qui ont vécu ce
genre de choses mais robert facile de
balayer les îles moi je vais vous vous
rendez beaucoup de motos discours face à
tous ces jeunes filles s'est dit que
vous n'avez pas le temps le dira que la
chari m'est arrivé mais vélo qui est
calme ce n'est pas lui même débat ce
n'est pas demandeur et vous avez france
compte demander où le rayon pour nous
d'être une erreur de jeunesse sans nous
rappeler ce n'est pas une erreur c'est
vous les uns les photos
même si j'ai
une candidate qui va me se rangent
parvus d'une femme de 19 ans de
n'importe quel âge elle n'a pas que ce
soit ma meilleure amie qui ai fait ça
j'aimerais pas que ce soit ma cousine
est vrai que ce soit ma mère j'aimerais
pas que ce soit juste
à kelly kelly vous avez vous êtes face à
vous pensez avoir été droguée ou pour
savoir un je ne sais pas ce qui m'a
servi un verre
voilà et je ne sais pas vous souvenez
pas de ces photos si bien sûr je les
appelais juste avant 2 mai dans les
journées que delà de la voilà comment
ces véhicules et épanouie 1 suppose
depuis je me rappelle j'étais super mal
quand je suis sorti j'ai même fait un
malaise enfin je quand vous avez autant
dénigrer très bien quoi ouais je voulais
plus j'ai déjà j'en ai parlé à personne
quand j'entends ce genre de discours
jean une vomir sincèrement oui messieurs
dames âgées un haut-le-coeur quand j'ai
vu les photos
affichées de ceux de blâmer les gens
essaient de les lire et je dis ça juste
avant sa mort est ce que c'est une
erreur de jeunesse et aujourd'hui on dit
j'ai eu un blackout ce qu'on fait
généralement une fois qu'on a été sous
et on dit j'ai fait de la merde mais en
fait j'ai fait un black out j'aimerais
bien plus si c'est exactement juste
voilà mais il faut pas oublier que ces
photos quand on les voit sortis du
contexte et des photos effectivement
très sale si vous êtes victime vous êtes
vie de
19 ans qui font des photos comme ça pour
se prouver des choses et ça non plus
c'est pas bien j'ai pas prude mais je
dis seulement que chacun doit se
respecter aussi bien sûr mais je pense
que si chacun sur ce plateau doit être
conscient de ce qu'il dit vraiment et y
avoue mais par exemple dans les journaux
masculin vous êtes jamais posé la
question d'où viennent certaines photos
d'illustration là je vais pas parler de
pornographie je vais parler de photos
érotiques des photos pour illustrer des
articles typiquement masculin
dans mon livre justement je propose je
vais proposer je vais être très
attentive aux à la future présidentielle
je voudrais proposer un durcissement sur
la loi contre le harcèlement sexuel et
notamment une seule espèce de la loi
sans courant c'est le point 6 de la loi
qui au sujet des fonds sur les photos on
l'a déjà dit plein de poids à tous les
jeunes qui nous a évité car là vous avez
déjà fait des castings nous aussi on est
d'accord que carla elle est magnifique
car il faut pas que taiwo la étudierait
aux jeunes de balises césar photographe
il vous dit voilà tu voulais faire un
bouquet qui commencent à vous demander
de faire des photos mais moi je pense
que c'est pas le problème de jeunes
relève peut-être que l a mal pris le
fait que vous ayez participé du kwassa
sachant que ce qui s'était passé
derrière moi je pense que c'est plus de
se dire bah l'image de miss france c'est
bête parfaite et bajaur en l'occurrence
elle connaissait ce qui s'était passé
elle s'est quand même présenté à cela
alors qu'on a eu un match très dur à
tenir mais après le passé de chacun
c'est le passé de chacun jean mais
surtout pour les jeunes qui nous
regardent et les jeunes filles qui nous
regardent surtout c'est surtout sur les
jeunes filles quand on a un photographe
vous dis bien la maison déjà je vous dis
pas ça signifie demande exactement si je
n'ai pas ça c'est
vous dit vous pouvez y aller on n'a pas
les miens et ne payez pas je vous dis ça
déjà c'est une filière a déjà quand on
vous demande de payer pour faire des
castings pour faire des photos ou de
venir à la maison sur groupé n'allait
pas ça c'est une énorme énorme arnaque
with you apparemment d'une fille mais je
trouve extrêmement avec kelly en fait le
débat c'est parce que c'est bien ou pas
bien de faire des photos sexy pas sexy
pornographiques pas pornographique elle
est en train de dire qu'elle est tombée
sur un photographe vers eux que ces
photos en plus ont été faits dans un
contexte privé et qu'elles ont été
extorqués ils se retrouvent publiées à
la une d'un magazine complet sont
d'accord c'est dégueulasse et aux
attentes et jugés parce que c'était
privé ça alors je remets pas en cause si
vous êtes fait mis enfin voilà ce que
vous êtes fait drogués c'est une chose
moi je parle juste de la qualité de la
photo une photo comme ça même à mon
copain j'en vois pas une foule et tout
le monde
dans
quelque chose de totalement
sexuelle pourquoi vous n'êtes pas de mon
côté et dénoncer ces pourritures là
c'est juste que ça me choque moi je me
faisais souvent le choc je me fait
photographier très souvent et si je me
mets en lingerie c'est parce que je les
biens volume voulu alors faut aussi
arrêter de dire que tous les
photographes ont lissé des pervers vous
en allez dire ça roule en vélo
ça reste un beau métier il ya plein il
ya plein de photographies au locle et
photos à l'appui allez faut accélérer
très facile quand on se dénude après de
dire en fait il m'a forcée pour
l'instant et toutes les chutes le nombre
de shooting que j'ai fait j'ai jamais
vécu ça mais toi mais
vous en mets beaucoup si vous vous êtes
fait drogués c'est une chose c'est un
mail je répète qu'il ya plein de jeunes
filles après l'adolescence est d'autant
plus maintenant sur snapshot surtout
elle se dénude parce qu'elles pensent
c'est comme ça qu'on peut y arriver il y
en a plein qui se dénude vraiment
vraiment des bars et qui font des photos
à la limite effectivement du plan d'eau
parce qu'elles pensent qu'elles peuvent
réussir et ça c'est très bien mais tu as
un problème de sa dette si
on à isabelle moi
je suis désolé je comprends tout à fait
et ce que vous dites je comprends tout à
fait le fond de moi j'ai quand même été
mal à l'aise parce que j'ai le sentiment
très net et là je rejoins un peu
delphine que vous surfiez sur une vague
que vous sauf et que le livre était
plutôt opportuniste sur le 10 ans et
pendant je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher du
début à la fin de me dire mais pourquoi
le sortir là maintenant je comprends
l'histoire de l'emprise de tout ce que
vous dites n'empêche que j'ai eu un
malaise où j'ai vraiment eu le sentiment
que c'était un livre opportunit je suis
désolé de coûts énormes je ne mets pas
en doute votre intégrité va durer la
sage qu'on pense que veut dire belle
fille mais je comprends mais je vais
vous répondre je suis mère de famille
maintenant j'ai deux enfants je le sors
douze ans plus tard parce que pour moi
c'est le bon moment pour quoi parce que
j'ai mûri par rapport à tout ça que je
me sens prête c'est un travail c'est par
le long processus
j'en ai vraiment j'ai énormément
souffert sama
ça m'a vraiment préparé à la suite ça
m'a préparé surtout à apprendre à mes
enfants à les éduquer à
à ce qu'ils ne fassent pas ces erreurs
là ce qu'ils soient hyper vigilant j'ai
une petite fille de 5 ans
excusez moi ça me mais je comprends les
points de vue qui l'hiver je comprends
complètement je comprends mais mon livre
n'est pas opportuniste j'ai écrit 4 135
pages
il fait pas 96 pages et pardon mais avez
vous lu liping
après après c'est vrai qu'on dit
beaucoup que pourquoi on en parlait
maintenant mais parce qu'aussi c'est
peut-être le sujet et peut-être que
justement quand y en a beaucoup qui en
parlent et bien au final on n'a plus de
force quand tout le monde en parle tant
que seul
d'en parler mais on se dit que c'est le
moment parce qu'il ya tout dire que vous
êtes en procès tout photographe
actuellement non non non et je plains
ces deux ans qu'elle fait le mort et
mais ce que personne en france il ya un
procès en tout cas enfin on y at il à
plusieurs casseroles parce qu'il ya
plusieurs victoires d'accord il est
voilà et dès les premiers jours mais ça
mon avocat de l'époque ne l'avaient pas
compris il ya une jeune femme qui était
me trouvais dans le bureau de mon avocat
en pleurs de 8 à thurey plus que moi
c'était les premiers jours du scandale
et puis en gros elle a reconnu le fameux
sièges en osier qu'on voit un moment
donné quand est il lui a fait la même
chose delphine pire que vous aimeriez
d'irak et 10 mois
maxi si elle est victime c'est c'est
vraiment horrible et sait très bien que
vous ayez sorti ce livre pour toutes les
jeunes filles merci bon
c'est ce que je voulais faire voilà
voulait alerter mois de but en blanc
c'est vrai que les photos je les ai vues
elles m'ont choqué sans doute qu'elle
vous choque pareil et elles ont choqué
toute votre famille puisque vous dire
que vous êtes une victime oui mais j'ai
envie juste aussi de rétablir que les
photographes il ya plein de photographes
justement qui seront pas payés parce
qu'il ya que des échanges des
collaborations faudra avons besoin de
bosser et les photographes c'est pas que
des pervers qu'il faut arrêter regardez
la couverture non livre j'avais 19 ans
sur cette couverture il m'a photographié
enceinte ces photographies
l'émerveillement mais voila voila c
c'est très important moi c'est aussi
quinze ans que je fais des photos et on
n'a jamais eu un seul qui m'a fait des
propositions c'est très important aussi
de ne pas jeter l'eau sale sur ces
ménages est là et pourrait bien sûr les
filles
y compris
[Rires]
c'est très bon pour ne pas salir ne pas
salir ces métiers là eh oui les filles
quand vous allez à un shooting photo
alesi à deux c'est toujours mieux à les
y accompagner c'est ça le message qu'il
faut passer ça mais faut arrêter de se
monter les uns contre les autres aussi
ses symboles il faut éviter de se jeter
de l'eau sale